today i'm really excited to be joined by
my close friend and colleague joshua
angrist a professor of economics also at
mit
and newly minted nobel prize winner for
his work on natural experiments in
economics
and by our colleague clemency du a
researcher at blueprint labs and an mit
phd graduate
today's talk will be pretty wide ranging
but will focus mainly on blueprint labs
research into admissions policies in
public schools
and their impacts on integration and
student achievement
i'll introduce josh and clements and get
into our discussion in just a moment but
first let me make a few housekeeping
notes
i'll ask josh and clements each to tell
us a little bit about themselves and
their work and then we'll get into a
discussion about their research and its
implications
what they've learned recommendations for
educators
and so on
uh for the last 15 minutes or so we'll
open it up to audience q a
at any time please feel free to put
questions for our panelists into the
chat
our moderators today janine and
catherine will be collecting all of the
questions for us to go through during
the q a
if you'd like to go on camera and ask
your question directly please use the
raise hand function on zoom and a
moderator will promote you to panelists
during the q a
and if you have any questions about any
of this please put them in the chat and
the moderators will help you so without
further ado let's get started
josh i'm going to start with you
josh angrist is the ford professor of
economics at mit a co-founder and
director of mit's blueprint labs and a
research associate at the national
bureau of economic research
josh can you tell us a bit about your
work
i'd love to barack thanks so much for
that very flattering introduction it's
been a
an unusually uh exciting semester for us
at the lab
usually we have
a lot of excitement anyway this has been
extra special this fall of course i'm
thrilled and humbled to
have been
recognized with a nobel prize and to
share uh the prize with my thesis
advisor one of my thesis advisors dave
card and my long time collaborator hito
embanks uh i have a couple of fun picks
to share with our audience let me see if
i can get that to work
um
from the nobel experience let's see if
that'll come up on my
ipad
um
so what we do in the lab is we we uh
estimate causal effects of things
related to schools so i think of that as
illuminating the path from cause to
effect and that's what the prize
recognizes that kind of work so uh
all of us at blueprint labs we couldn't
be more pleased by this and it really is
a group effort at the lab it's been a
little disruptive so that's what i um
came home to early on
october 11th photographers in my
driveway i'm holding my granddaughter
and that's my wife mira there and
it's more or less been like that uh ever
since i'm looking forward to going back
to work uh having a little coffee and
getting up to a quieter
day
but it is inspiring to get the prize uh
there's an inspiring quote in stephen
pinker's latest book which i think
uh reflects uh the way i feel about
the work that we do
i was surprised to see this in the book
and it means that we're sort of really
getting our tools out there when a data
scientist finds a regression
discontinuity or an instrumental
variable it's a really good day and i'm
hoping that i've uh i've made those days
better for some people with the work
that i do
at blueprint um
you know i'm very lucky to have such
fine collaborators at the lab like parag
and our our talented student clements
we've been working
as a team for for uh over a decade on
questions related to schools we work on
school assignment uh how kids choose and
are offered opportunities to attend
different schools and we work on school
effectiveness
which we typically measure by
the learning gains or the effects of
school attendance on
how likely uh students are to eventually
go to college these sound like fairly
quotidian matters but uh as you'll soon
see uh uh in clemenza's presentation and
she's really the star of the show today
this is the heart of the matter for one
of the most controversial and important
questions in american public life and
that that's the question of of
integration racial integration in
schools
and what sort of policies uh facilitate
integration and what sort of policies
inhibit it and uh closely related to
that is the question of school
effectiveness whether uh opportunities
to attend different schools indeed uh
promote learning and and lead to better
outcomes
school quality for many people is really
life-changing and i like to make this
point by mentioning a paper uh that
david card who's one of the prize
winners
the nobel that i share
wrote with our late friend alan krueger
in the early 90s
they showed that improvements in school
quality
really explains
a substantial fraction of the gain
gains in earnings
of black men in the 1960s and 70s and
there was great progress in in in terms
of the racial earnings gap in those
decades uh not complete convergence by
any means we have a long way to go but
progress nonetheless and a lot of that
progress is explained by increasing
school quality uh increasing increases
in the quality of the schools that that
black men
attend uh the re we focus on men
typically in research from that period
because female labor force participation
rates were relatively low
in any case uh
the topic today is uh is certainly um
interesting and exciting and and
relevant to current policy debates um
perad clements and i have uncovered all
sorts of interesting findings related to
the effects of going to schools of
different types in boston chicago and
new york
and as part of her thesis work clemens
has has taken a deep dive into the
consequences of an unprecedented change
in um new york city assignment policies
and an effort to reduce segregation in
two of the city's highest income
areas they're called districts because
new york is so big uh even smaller parts
of new york are called school districts
in any case i'll hand off now to
clements and i'll let her tell this
remarkable story
great j josh thank you so much um come
on um the show is yours
thank you for the introduction
uh let me share like uh some slides that
i can show you some pictures as well
that won't be as funny as your picture
i'm afraid but that's hard to
to beat
and so like as um i think george said
like i i received my phd from mit this
year and i'm a postdoctoral fellow at
mit department of economics and
blueprint labs
and so during my phd i focus my research
on understanding what are the
consequences of school assignment rules
on student achievement
and school diversity so what i mean is
like whether you can design a system of
co-admission that can increase school
diversity or increase like test scores
and
in today i will focus on my work in new
york city so i've been like studying the
past two years the consequences of new
york city integration policies
and as a starting point from this
project was the observation that
american school district are still very
much segregated although more than
almost 70 years have elapsed since uh
born versus board of education which is
as you may know the supreme court ruling
that uh order all school districts
across the u.s to desegregate so
to give you a number like roughly 17
percent of american schools today enroll
a student body that is approximately 75
percent black or hispanic students
there's a lot of discrepancy on the
student body of a different school in
the u.s
and this has like um
driven a lot of media attention and when
the public debate talks about this
question it often focuses on the
question of racial differences in access
to selected and roman schools so
selective and mormon schools are schools
that select students based on a past
achievement or other characteristics and
like to to cite some like for instance a
free exam school in boston artificially
selected enrollment schools because they
select people based on uh on the result
at an exam
um during like the community pandemic
testing was interrupted in many cities
in the u.s and as a result there was
like an increased interest
in screen school access and this is
reflected by like the some articles i've
pulled over like in the screen here and
for instance like in virginia the first
high school board decided to eliminate
admission tests to its very selective
and prestigious high schools it turned
us different from high school last year
uh in boston so like just uh on the
other side of the river from here uh bps
have um enacted two successive admission
reforms in the past two years
and uh this admission reform targeted
the city three exam schools
so there's like free school that in
boston that select student based on an
exam those are like um
upper middle school and high school like
this extreme from seventh grade on and
so as the city like the two successive
rounds of admission reform were slightly
different but basically the idea was to
give some
preparation access to this to this very
spacious school to students from lower
um
like from disadvantaged backgrounds like
the city created some a system of
priority for these students so that they
would get a better access to these very
prestigious folks
in new york city finally last year the
new york city
school board decided to
suspend
academic screen for admission at its
middle school for a year and uh the
suspension has been like extended for
another year this year seems like the
city didn't have any like test car to be
admission on so there's like there has
been like this very this temporary
suspension of screening in middle
schools
um
so like
just to say that like there has been
like this increased interest in like
this issue of like whether uh this
elective and mission policies are
contributing to segregation in the in
american schools
new york city is quite an interesting
place to study this question because
first it's the largest school district
in the united states so the district as
you may know enroll like roughly one
million of students every year and
that's like approximately 0.3 percent of
the u.s population
the district is also deemed one of the
most segregated in the country so like
to give you a number like 50 percent of
schools in your city enroll like more
than us 90 percent of black and hispanic
students that are also eligible for free
and reduced price lunch that is a vice
disparity of the
student population and roman aqua
schools
your city is also interesting because
it's a city in which uh screen schools
are very prevalent so roughly one third
of new york city middle and high school
screen student unpassed academic
performance in 2018 so prior to the
suspension of academic screening uh one
third of middle schools in new york city
were admitting students based on their
past performance so like you would get
like your admission out of school based
on whether you did well in elementary
school
so in response to this challenge in 2019
to like a new york city school district
so as josh said new york city is very
big and so it's divided in 32 local
school districts that you can see in
this picture and two of them so the
upper west side district which is in
blue up there and the northwest brooklyn
um district which is in orange down here
so like it's like in the northwest of
brooklyn
um decided to adopt diversity management
plans
so
the idea behind these plans were to try
to integrate the middle school
in these two districts of the city which
is as josh pointed out the wealthiest
district in the city and also the two
districts in which segregation was very
prevalent
and so this district decided to reduce
the role of academic screens in
emissions and in order like to try to
increase integration at the uh district
schools
so then in my research what i have tried
to to understand is whether this reform
uh worked out so whether like actually
like um they achieved uh their aim and
uh what were their uh consequences in
terms of enrollment and application
behavior from a family so whether this
this reform had like other consequences
on how people choose the school they
apply to and which school they decide to
enroll in
so like just like um
i want like to present like three key
findings from this research uh before
like diving into the first finding i
just wanted to like give you some more
background information about like what
exactly these two districts did
so like this district um so
they both like um united reformed by 19
and their reform were slightly different
so like in upper west side
what the district did was that they
decided to keep academic screenings so
like students would still be screened
based on the past test course uh when
they they were applying for middle
school but they set aside 25 percent of
seats in each middle school for
uh students that are eligible for
reduced price lunch or um and have low
test scores so if you were a student in
the upper west side and you had like a
test score below a certain threshold and
you were also eligible for 300 price
lunch then you would get a priority for
this 25 percent of states and so the
idea was to like expand the access to
this school to students that were low
income and low achieving
in northwest brooklyn the reform was a
bit more radical so the idea was like
the district decided actually to
eliminate all academic screen so
what that means
is that middle school would only and
meet students based on their lottery
number so like in new york city every
year like students are assigned lottery
number and that determines in part their
admission and so in norfolk brooklyn
after the reform in 2019
um students would be admitted only based
on that number and not based on their
past academic performance
the district also set aside 50 to 52 of
seats for students who are low-income
uh english language learners are
homeless so which means that a student
that would qualify for these like um
seed priority would get a um would be
like put first on the list when they
when the when the school were filling
their seats so they think that like they
would get an extra priority for this 52
percent of seats
and so like so the first thing i found
in my research is that this policy that
reduced the role played by academic
screens decreased rational and economic
economies called segregation to some
extent
and so that's what i'm i'm showing you
here so in this like uh maybe a
complicated graph they're like i'm
displaying you the evolution of school
segregation
uh for like both districts so in uh in
blue you can see like the evolution of
school segregation or upper west side in
orange or northwest brooklyn any great
for other new york city school districts
the left panel like is school
segregation for low-income students so
that correspond to a measure of school
segregation
economic school segregation
while the right panel is school
segregation for black and hispanic
students so that corresponds to measure
thrash of school segregation
as you may see like for like the gray
line it's like flats which means that
there was no change in school
segregation in other districts in the
city which makes sense because there was
no change in policy
whereas like we can see like a decrease
in school segregation for uh northwest
brooklyn after the uh enactment of the
of the reforms like segregation with
roughly of 15 percentage and it like
dropped around like 10 percentage points
uh hour to 10 percent that after the
refund uh for northwest for upper west
side the future is less clear the
decrease is less marked and he's like is
um he's consistent with the fact that
the plan they adopted was a bit less
radical
as you can see as well like the drop in
segregation is more mark
uh for a low-income student than for
black and hispanic students so that
means that there was a high a larger
decrease in economic school segregation
than russian specifically
so the second key finding of my research
was that
actually families reacted to this reform
and they reacted by changing their
application and enrollment behaviors
so what i mean by that is that like as a
when finally decided where to enroll uh
what i found is that after the reform uh
some group of students were more likely
to enroll in a school outside the
traditional public school system
so they were more likely not to enroll
in a new york city public school but to
enroll either in a charter or a private
school and the group of students that
were more likely to exit the public
school system
was like white and higher income
students
specifically they were like six to eight
percent at each point more likely to
enroll in a school that was outside the
traditional political system
and like to give you an idea like the
baseline rate of enrollment outside the
public schools system is of ten percent
in upper west side and seventeen percent
you know great people
so this increase in exits is substantial
on the other hand black hispanic asian
and lower income students were
unaffected so they enrolled the same
rate in public school after they
reformed them before
then i like i tried to investigate why
how white
white white and higher income students
were more likely to exit and what i
found is that
uh family seems to be responding to the
fact that after the reform uh their uh
children were assigned to school with
lower achieving peers on average so like
it seems to be the case that families
are leaving the district in response to
these uh to the fact that they were
assigned to school in which like the the
peers the classmates of their kid would
have had lower test scores
on the application side what i found is
that there was also a
change in the set of schools finally is
applied to so after the the reform
family started applying to more schools
and a student that were achieving so
that had like lower grades in elementary
schools decided to apply to more
competitive schools and like these uh
application response tended to increase
the effectiveness of the client so
because like students that were lower
achieving and like their offensive lower
income ended up applying to school that
were enrolling more uh higher income
students
finally like as a last step of my
analysis what i tried to do is to
understand what would happen if the city
was to enact a similar reform
and um
so like i i basically like perform a
simulation of like what would a school
suggestion look like in new york city if
the city was to change its admission
system
uh that's why i'm like showing you in
these bar charts and this bar chart you
have the level of segregation in a
purple
and under the actual
admission regime
then in green i have like a
counterfactual and mission regime in
which the city is not using academic
achievement to screen students anymore
and finally in right you have like a
regime in which buff as a city is not
using either academic sprints or uh
geographies prints what i mean by
geography screens is like screening
based on where this is student live so
like
uh in new york city you may get like
some priority because you live close to
a school and so if the city was also to
drop this kind of priority you would get
to the uh um red bar
so from this picture what you can see is
that the drop in segregation is much
larger when the city is also dropping
geographic screens we tend to entail
that like geographic screen are a bigger
driver of segregation than academic
screens
but you can also see that there is still
residual segregation even when the city
is not admitting students based on
either academic or geographic sprints
and is like crystal segregation is
purely due to family preferences and
residual and residential segregation so
the fact that like the city is
segregated by people from different uh
race and different socioeconomic
background live in different
neighborhoods and they tend to
send their kids to different school and
also to apply to different schools so
even like if the city were not to use
any admission criteria to admit you into
the schools you would still have like
these uh remaining segregation
so like taking stuff like um
i think that's what i learned from this
project is that admission reform has the
potential for curbing segregation in
your city schools and uh why i'm saying
that is because roughly fifty percent of
schools education is accounted by
academic and geographic admission
strengths
um geography screening appear actually
to be more important than i can
experience so like if the city was
willing to like lower segregation more
according to my simulation it would be
more effective to drop geographic
sprints
nonetheless like one have to take into
account that it appears that white and
high income applicants could exit the
traditional public school district in
response to such reform so it's like
unclear like to what extent they would
but like it seemed to be the case that
uh white and high incomes applicants
tend to exit the public school district
when uh there is like an admission
reform the dhc importance of strange
um i think that like this is uh
interesting uh if you put it into the
context like in the context that uh new
york city is actually currently
considering further admission reforms so
in particular the city has been
discussing the removal of geographic
screens in high schools
and the phase out of guilty and talented
foreign elementary schools and so i'm i
mean in light of my analysis i would be
curious to see whether like these
policies are implemented and how they
fare if they are implemented
and
i think that's uh all i had to say so
i'm going to give it back to barack
horrific commands thank you so much uh
that's a
really fascinating and topical work um
what i want to do
now is um open it up to a conversation
with you and also um with josh before
opening it more generally to
the the broader audience and clemons let
me start off just by asking a couple of
questions
uh about your work um
and um you know you mentioned new york
city is the nation's largest school
district and um
a lot of the country has been paying
attention to the efforts to try to
integrate the upper west side and
northwest brooklyn
uh what i wanted to ask you about is if
you could speak on what the reaction has
been from your contacts in new york city
to your results and more generally if
you could say a bit more about
your relationship with the folks at the
department of education and what it's
been like to do research that is so
topical and uh sometimes emotionally
charged
um
yeah so like his research was like
mostly like um possible because of the
collaboration of the new york city
office of enrollment and research
um and i think that was like a very
interesting part of the work actually
like this collaboration
um
because like so like they bring a more
like a policy oriented approach to the
work and they know better what like it's
playing on the ground like what are like
policy makers worries like like families
are saying reaction to this policy and
so it was like great like um a very good
uh interaction to orient the research
until i understand what might be
important and what might be feasible
um
i'm like um so like in general i think
that like um
[Music]
these like this kind of like policy
maker and academic like uh interaction
are like very like relevant for research
and like you give you a different
perspective from your work that like
what you would have just by like looking
at your result by yourself and it was
very enriching for me like to
collaborate with the new york city
school district and get like their
feedback on my work and it was a very
much like uh we had like a lot of
discussion on when like when i was
developing the work and i i could take
into account the reaction to like my
early findings so that was quite
interesting
um that's great it seems like that
partnership has been quite fruitful
um
and
let me turn to another question um
which is uh is maybe gonna ask you to
speculate a little bit more so you
mentioned some of the the new reforms
that were proposed
and we've just had a an election in new
york city where there's a new mayor
and new york city is a school district
where the mayor has a lot of control it
doesn't have an elected school board
unlike many other cities
um what are the big issues in new york
city schools these days and
you know if you could whisper into the
ear of the the mayor and the new
superintendent about uh the the coming
issues
what would you tell them about what they
should focus on
based you know you know based on your
research and and you know your knowledge
on this topic
um
oh that's a that's a great question
um
so
so i think so there has been a lot of so
well i think that
actually like here you mentioned that um
that the mayor has a lot of power so
there's also a lot of uncertainty of
what's going on and i think that like
something i've seen a lot in my work is
that like a parental understanding of
the system is somewhat limited sometimes
so i think that like a very basic thing
that like that would be useful in new
york city is to have a better
communication between like um parents
and administration so um like you know
that's like like actually like the
referring district 15 was a great
example of that in which like the reform
went relatively smoothly uh even though
it was like actually dropping all
academic screens because there was a lot
of community involvement and so that's
like something that um
that maybe like would be useful because
we've been talking a lot about like all
the possible admission reform that could
happen and every time it seems like
there's a backlash and there's not much
like understanding of what's gonna
happen next so like that i think that
that would be like an interesting like
uh like in terms of admission policies
it would be a great um
like quite important to get like the
communication clear also because it
seems to be that these uh some virus to
information in new york city so like
there was like a study a couple of years
ago that showed that like students
didn't really understand what their
options were and so that like that could
be like a step um
like
an easier life step to take than like
overhauls in a whole like emission
system just to get like to reduce
barrier of information
terrific great um let me see if we can
um try to get josh also to weigh in on
our next question here
and this is a question a bit more about
what economists bring to debates about
education policy you know so much of the
conversation about efforts to integrate
and desegregate schools are based on
kind of strong moral and ethical
arguments
uh arguments that date you know at least
to the brown versus board of education
decision in the 1950s
and brown casts a very long shadow on uh
even debates in the current era
i'm curious what does an economist
someone who works with numbers really
have to say about these moral and
ethical issues how does an economist
approach questions about the effects of
segregation
josh maybe you want to go first and then
we'll hand it to clements
uh sure well i don't know if i could
speak for all economists of course uh
but
speaking for myself and
um
i think this is the ethos in the lab
you know
uh we have we would like to see
schools integrated but
um we don't you know we we approach
questions related to segregation and
school
assignment and school effectiveness
you know dispassionately i think that's
our
primary contribution we're interested in
the consequences
of for example d screening
d screening is well intentioned but that
doesn't mean that it works out well
you know we need to consider
the consequences of that uh did that
actually increase
access and
also we need to confront possibilities
like white flight and clematis study
addresses these issues beautifully and
and she approaches it with
you know without any preconceived
notions and and the facts are there
uh you know for
uh policymakers to consider of course
that's not the only
consideration that's relevant but i
think it's it's essential to know what
the actual consequences of an
intervention
like d screening um
are and and our our role is to provide
that kind of objective information
uh and then it's up to decision makers
uh how they use it but we can also help
guide that discussion we
for example simulations of the kind that
commands does
uh can be used to explore
consequences of things that have not yet
been tried
so for example de-screening city-wide
there our results are more speculative
but again you know we approach these
problems and questions as scientists
when we answer the question what are the
consequences of discreting de-screening
you know then there's a separate
follow-on step which is how that
information is used
thank you josh clements maybe um
i can ask you just to add a couple of
thoughts on how economists you know have
looked at the effects of segregation
either in new york or elsewhere
yeah so i think that like something that
i've not i haven't touched on and that
that is interesting is like whether the
effect also like in as josh points out
in our life we're very interested in the
effect on test scores and maybe also on
other like uh
measure of development of of freedom and
like this not something like that is
like very like excellent evidence uh as
of now so like that's like something
that would be quite interesting like to
see more work on the future so there are
some evidence that like in uh
when um
when like your desegregation happened
the
1780s uh that was a 60s 70s that were
being that was beneficial to black
students that had an increasing test
course and the last week like it's hard
to know whether it was because of
increasing funding or just to exposure
to more diverse fears so that like
something that uh clearly like
an economist like would be interested in
studying um there are like barriers like
uh it's not like an easy question to
tackle and like this setting would have
been a good one but there's no test for
so i like there there's some limits here
but clearly like that's something which
like economists could weigh in which is
more like the
diamonds of benefit from integration and
there's not like very like striking
evidence for that in a recent more
recent years so like
um there are some evidence from
like
historical desegregation effects but not
like from like these like more
contemporary efforts
terrific great
um
now um let's maybe zoom out a little bit
from new york city uh it is the big
apple but um
uh there are other cities clemonts that
you've studied and josh has also studied
um
maybe come on so you could tell us a
little bit about some of the research
you've done with boston public schools
um the questions you've looked at the
approaches and what you've been finding
um yes that's like actually like related
in the sense that um so in boston i
study like exam school and mission
policies um
and what i was interesting there is was
to understand like whether you could
actually increase test score by uh
changing the admission policies so i was
not so much focused focusing on
diversity but more like trying to
understand like could you like design a
system in which you raise test score in
the city by just changing who gets
admitted to an exam school
and what i find is actually that
contrary like to what one would believe
uh it's not like the characteristic of
the student that matters much so it's
not because a student is a high
achieving student that he would benefit
more from an exam school it's more it's
not also like minority students don't
appear to be benefiting more from
attending an exam school what seems to
matter is more is like which school uh
is their alternative school so like
which school would have the student
would which would have been the outside
option of this school of this student if
they had not been admitted to an exam
school and so i found that actually like
if you were to design a system in which
you give priority to students that have
that living neighborhood in which the
neighborhood school is of worse quality
you get like a
higher test score for the city
what is interesting is that a
neighborhood in
schools are not partially good are not
necessarily neighborhood in which a lot
of low-income and uh minority students
live in boston so it is not necessarily
related to the test score of the student
either so like you need like to be to
try to actually measure uh what is
what the school is providing to the kid
and not just like look at
what are the characteristics of the kids
so if you want to design such a system
you need to actually understand what
like what is the value added of this
book which is like uh something us
economists like care a lot about which
is what's the school add to a freedom
test score and not only what what is it
the key test score at the end of the
school because otherwise you might just
be so lighting on kids that would have
had like very high tests for anyone so
what i've i find in like this other line
of research is that you could actually
like try to design a system in which you
target students that have low value
added alternative and that's more
efficient so that's a different
perspective on admission that is not so
much focus on diversity but more on like
how the school system can raise test
score by just changing very like um
more administrative roles of amnesia
terrific and and commands that work in
boston um
yeah boston has actually made some
serious changes you mentioned in your
slides to their admissions policy
um
for these exam schools
um taking into account um aspects of
where kids live
is is that right is that on the table
still in the city terrific um
um josh maybe i'll i'll turn to you um
so uh the lab that you co-direct um
works in new york and
boston could you tell us a bit more
about uh kind of education topics that
um folks at the lab have addressed your
your own work um maybe in other cities
or uh in other settings
sure
um so the lab
that we
share broadly uh covers
two sorts of
education topics we have our k-12
division
and uh
that
looks at public education in
large urban districts like boston new
york chicago new orleans
washington and
cities especially of interest to us have
some kind of centralized
assignment and that's something else so
that the lab specializes in
in studying uh how kids are offered
seats in districts that have a lot of
choice new york is really uh the most uh
interesting because it has first of all
such a huge place and it has so many
schools and they have a very
interesting choice system which mixes
some element of random assignment
actually lotteries are involved in that
but not only you also have the screen
schools that come on talked about and
you have the legendary specialized high
schools like stuyvesant brooklyn tech
and bronx science we're very interested
in who gets to go to these different
schools and what the consequences of
going to them are
we also study a lot of uh the most
exciting and potentially controversial
education policy reform
projects we've looked extensively
for the past decade at different sorts
of charter schools in different
districts and we have a lot of
interesting results there
i think one of our most
exciting set of findings uh in that
domain is
is the results for chicago
where actually
kids you know in chicago so by way of
background chicago has a large
exam school sector uh you know schools
that are uh competitive and highly
selective like peyton and northside
and uh what's uh kind of surprising
about those schools is that they
actually seem to
reduce the achievement of their
applicants uh when the applicant is
actually is offered a seat in that
sector
and we
puzzled over that um you know maybe exam
schools are not uh great
maybe there's a lot of selection bias in
terms of who actually gets to go to the
exam schools but why should they reduce
achievement and that turns out to be
to have a simple uh but maybe surprising
explanation a lot of the kids who apply
to chicago's exam schools have also
applied to a very successful charter
network called the noble network of
charter schools charter high schools and
um it's more impressive to get into an
exam school because that's selective
whereas noble admits by lottery so kids
who apply to both noble and charter tend
to to apply to both noble and exam tend
to take an exam offer when they get it
and that means that the likelihood that
they go to a charter is reduced and
those charters are very high performing
and kids would have actually learned
more and been more likely to go to
college if they had gone to the charter
school so that's a striking finding
and uh uh sure to be uh controversial uh
uh uh when we publish it the uh other uh
uh uh dimension of education reform
where we have some potentially
controversial findings
is uh research on vouchers of course
perak knows this well because he's the
the leader of the voucher team
uh barag and his co-authors have studied
a
very interesting voucher program in
louisiana
where kids who apply to
kids who attend public schools that are
deemed by the state to be low performing
may get vouchers it's not guaranteed
there's an element of random assignment
there too and we take advantage of the
random assignment of the louisiana
voucher program to estimate causal
effects and you know it turns out
good hopes and
and expectations for vouchers
notwithstanding voucher winners in
louisiana tend to come out of that
program with lower test scores
and i don't remember if you guys looked
at college in that study as well just
test scores
younger kids and it's a short run but
that that is also quite surprising
because you know the parents who are
applying for those vouchers uh imagine
that they're getting a real opportunity
there but then actually the causal
effect of going to a voucher school in
louisiana seems to be negative so um
another reason i want to tell these
stories together the chicago exam school
and the vouchers is i think it
highlights
something i mentioned earlier which is
in the lab we don't approach any of
these questions with any sort of
predisposition to find
that something is good or bad you know
we're open to what the data say we're
not pro charter and we're not
uh pro-exam and we're not pro-voucher
we're not anti-voucher we're not
anti-charter we're just studying those
things and we have a lot of interesting
findings and the results don't align
with any particular ideological uh
predispositions i think i'll just
briefly mention that another part of the
work that the lab does is related to
higher education
and we have a very large ambitious and
ongoing randomized evaluation of
financial aid in the post-secondary
sector so these are
kids in nebraska
who
are applying to nebraska's public
schools public universities and colleges
and
there's a foundation there
many will have heard the name the
buffett foundation
that pays for about 10 percent of
nebraska's public college and university
students tuition
and we worked uh i
are still working with the buffett
foundation in a in a study that
randomly allocates some vouchers to some
kids so that we could find not vouchers
sorry some post-secondary awards
uh uh they're sort of like vouchers but
uh it's just cash uh and but it can only
be used for public colleges and
universities and we're studying the
effects of of uh higher education
financial aid on educational attainment
they're the kids who uh get that sort of
very generous and it is exceptionally
generous aid that the buffett foundation
pays for they provide every dollar of
college-related costs there's sort of an
official number for that that the
federal government computes so they pay
tuition they pay room and board they pay
books and fees and so on
um but there's still a question as to
what the actual impact of that money is
because a lot of the beneficiaries might
have been likely to complete college
anyway the money may not be
consequential for them so that's the
kind of question that we're answering in
that study we have very interesting
findings there uh which show that sort
of overall there is uh there is an
impact of financial aid on
post-secondary attainment
but there are many kids who were going
to get
bas anyway
uh and uh uh there are then there are
groups where the aid is super high
impact and and our findings suggest that
a more targeted program would be likely
to be much more effective in terms of
increasing post-secondary attainment
thank you josh and thanks clements it's
a common theme about these studies that
designing more effective policies
require studying the consequences of
existing public policies and
there is hope and optimism that we can
actually make resources be allocated
more efficiently let me turn now to some
questions that we're getting uh from
the folks who've logged on today
and there are a couple of questions that
are quite related so let me try to
combine them
um kenneth wise and clements maybe i'll
come to you first on this kenneth wise
is asking a question about um
is there a lower bound on the degree of
segregation
say in new york city
and i think that's related to another
question here about the role of
residential sorting patterns
in driving
school segregation patterns
so a related question is asking about
whether systems that have better public
transportation or better uh busing would
uh go further to try to
integrate um cities like new york um so
clemons i know you've you've looked into
that a little bit so maybe you could
tell us
yeah that's that's a
that's a great point and um so what i i
did like in my in my study is that i
further decomposed the figure i showed
you so i looked at whether i could
explain the residual segregation in the
system and in particular i wanted to
understand
what share of this residual segregation
was due to um just like families liking
different schools and what share was due
to like families living in different
places like they all like the same kind
of schools but some people happen to be
much farther and so they decide not to
send their kids there and what i find is
like of the results aggregation 50 is
driven just by residential sorting so
which means that like uh even if like we
imagine in a warning with everybody like
the same school uh there will still be
like one quarter of the segregation we
see today in new york city just due to
the fact that people don't want to
commute hours to go to school
uh it's like to like so probably in
these like settings like if like public
transportation was better you could
probably like reduce these uh this
residual segregation due to
us um residential segregation even more
but as of today with the current like
level of transportation roughly like um
a quarter of the total segregation is
just due to the pattern of residential
sorting in the city
and new york city like a point on that
new york city is quite peculiar because
residential segregation in your city is
strong but is that a look it's at a
small geographical scale which means
that like
in your immediate surroundings people
tend to be of your
same socioeconomic background or race
but like if you go like a mile away
already you're like going to another
community so that makes it a city that
is relatively easier to integrate that
the city like chicago for instance which
is like
like segregation is a much larger scale
than in new york city
thank you clements um there's another
question also about your work um that i
want to turn to next so bob moo has
asked a question about um information
and involvement of parents in these
changes to enrollment policies
so you know new york city in the
upper west side and in northwest
brooklyn
both of those areas used an income quota
and they had to set
you said 25 percent in the upper west
side and more than 50 percent
in northwest brooklyn
how did they arrive at those numbers how
did they communicate those numbers to
the public um
and you know is income the right thing
to target in designing these policies or
should something else like you know your
fallback option
as you mentioned earlier or uh your race
uh be a better uh proxy
um so like for like the first part of
the question
so uh for like i i'm i know
i know i have more information of what
brooklyn process but for like in their
case like the process lasted two years
and there was like several reports that
were made before they arrived at the
current policy there were a lot of like
uh group work at the local level so
that's like how they like decided on the
actual policy they they implemented uh
they decide for 52 because of the share
of uh um friend reduced price lunch
students in the district so that's why
it's like this kind of arbitrary number
but it's coming from somewhere like it's
like 50 250.
uh for this week free for a website i
have less
information i know that they also had
like community meetings
and
and so there was like discussion with
the stakeholders for sure uh for like
district 15 it took like a couple of
years to get to the policy so it was not
an immediate thing
and
as a second question like who should
like
should the city be targeting something
else
uh like this so it's not like um
[Music]
you can't target by race because like uh
it's forbidden by a super supreme court
ruling from 2007. so like clearly like
yeah
like some cities have decided to use
proxies like your income is relatively
good proxy for that but like that's not
something you can legally do in any case
should you like target on other things i
think it really depends on what you're
trying to achieve so if you're trying to
achieve like a decrease in segregation
probably income is a good uh it's a it's
like really a good a good proxy uh if
you're trying to increase test score
then you might like be interested more
in looking what are the options of
students because it's not always true
that like lower income students have
necessarily the worst option so it can
be the case but it's not necessarily the
case and so that's like where we're
going back to the theme of like trying
to
uh really like take like the data as it
is and like you could like try to
understand new york city which are the
option for each kid then like how like
you would design a policy uh in the
basis of this observation uh i know for
boston that is not the case necessarily
that warring can go to the worst school
of the city but it might be the case in
new york city i haven't really like
looked at that but that's not an
empirical question and in any case it
depends on what are your aims or what
are you trying to achieve are you trying
to achieve integration are you trying to
achieve like higher test scores like
what are like what is your aim as a
policy maker
terrific comments um we're getting close
to the near uh the end of our time
together um so i want to wrap up with
two questions one for clemons first and
then one for josh
uh so clements i know all of us in the
economics department and blueprint labs
were so thrilled when josh was awarded
the nobel prize
uh this year and i wonder if you could
just offer some comments on what it's
like working with josh and what it's
like when your phd advisor wins a nobel
prize
um maybe i should sign up
[Laughter]
no no i have a good story actually so
when i join my team
we are assigned to talk to uh two people
when we go and visit days
and actually i had read like josh books
on koza in france and like you know he
was like kind of god for me and so i was
like i don't want to meet with him
because i'm way too scared to look
stupid
and i think that like something i've
learned a lot like during this year is
that you can't look too stupid in front
of josh like it's okay to say stupid
things
like and that's like so i think that's
something i really enjoyed like working
with josh is that i learned a lot
and i i felt that like it was okay not
like to be always right and actually
that's how you learn like really you
can't be always right and i find like
that's a very enriching part of our of
these like of this opportunity of
working with judges like to learn from
the best and like even like have like
this kind of very collegial spirit in
which you are not like you don't fear
saying something stupid anymore so i'm
very like grateful of the opportunity
oh that's very nice clematis yeah
there's an old saying if we weren't
confused it wouldn't be called research
right
exactly um
no stupid question
josh let me let me uh have you uh answer
the last question today so uh um i know
you're about to actually receive
uh the nobel prize in a couple of days
and unfortunately you're not able to go
to stockholm because of covid
uh concerns but maybe sometime in the
near future
you know when you
look back and reflect on all the
excitement of the past year i wonder if
you had any parting thoughts for the
next generation people like clements and
other scholars that are burgeoning
starting their research careers on
uh you know how to proceed with your
research life and um
any other tips that you want to pass on
uh sure brock yeah we're getting our
medals in washington on monday
unfortunately
can't go to stockholm and meet the gig
but hopefully the king will wait for us
next year
uh but uh
the
you know in some ways the
the nobel is kind of a distraction i i
love my work and
i hope to be able to get back to it
uh after all this uh ceremonial stuff is
taken care of of course i'm i'm
flattered and honored but
uh i'm lucky to have a job that i love
and um
i think that's what our
students are headed for our graduate
students uh they're they're
i hope they'll join uh join me in loving
their work and
uh you know it's not that every minute
is is a good time
uh but uh we
have a lot of intellectual challenge and
one of the wonderful things about our
lab is also
it's not just um
you know it's not just
thinking about things improving theorems
we're very engaged in
in the real world
we interact with lots of school
districts and educators and
people who are involved in education
policy and that's very enriching and it
helps us
keep our eye on the ball that there's
actual children out there in school and
that educational policy affects their
lives and their futures so
you know we're great we're just very
lucky we get to do something that really
affects a lot of people's lives
and it's super interesting and
challenging work i can't think of a
better job
great josh i can see the passion oozing
out as you talk uh um so
um i think we're just at time so i
wanted to thank everyone uh clements
josh uh the folks from the open learning
office
the folks at mightily and mit more
generally
thank you all for joining in and
participating and for your questions
and
that's a wrap thanks everyone